aside from fly fishing and things like
that was there ever a time when you set
out to do something different with your
life or did you know that you wanted to
be in this industry for I always wanted
to be an actor always from the time I
was a little boy but that's not what I
went to school to do or the business
that I originally got into when I left
school I was in the broadcast news
business doing radio and television news
and I started in Chicago and moved
around the country to a bunch of
different cities and and wound up in San
Diego working at a news talk radio
station this morning news anchor and i
also had kind of a little side voiceover
career there as well and I'm a
ventriloquist and I can imitate
airplanes flying over to wow I'm
speaking at the same time and my and I
heard about a television movie that was
shooting in San Diego they were looking
for some guy to play a detective I
thought hmm I could probably do that
look like a detective and I went to my
agent my voiceover agent I said can you
please get me an audition for this TV
movie and she said no no what do you
mean no she said you're a voice you're a
voiceover person you're not an actor oh
wow don't ever say that to a voiceover
person because I don't think there's a
more elevated form of acting man
voiceover because you only have your
voice keep touching your microphone I'm
sorry you only have your voice you only
have one one way to to create this great
texture of a performance anyway she said
no she wouldn't send me to the audition
I begged her and I begged her and I
begged her and she finds all right i'll
send you to the audition but if you
don't book this don't ever ask me again
and I said okay and so I went
and I booked the role of this detective
in this silly back in the days when they
used to call the movies of the week and
it was my very first job on television I
got to work with Linda gray and Linda
pearl and Kent McCord who I just saw
yesterday over at my voiceover agents
office i love Kent and Ernie lively who
was my detective partner Ernie's such a
great actor and I was you know terrified
it was my first time ever on a
television set and it was awful it was
nerve-racking and horrible and I i think
my performance was tested just awful it
was horrific but then i went to audition
for another one and I book that one and
another one and I book that one and
finally I thought well if I want to play
the game I'm going to have to really
live where the game is being played so I
moved from San Diego to Los Angeles and
haven't looked back since then of course
I've had it I had a day job for the
first couple of years um what did you do
oh wow I sold Lincoln automobiles Santa
Monica lincoln-mercury I worked as a
maintenance guy at a marina in Marina
del Rey at an apartment complex in
marina where I was constantly having to
unplug drains that some of the tenants
would pour candle wax down not knowing
apparently you're being smart enough to
realize that you don't pour candle wax
down your drains I sold shoes I was
horrific you know you do what you have
to do to put food on the table and meet
your obligations so what about the
voiceover work did that continue once
you got to LA cuz now you're even more
immersed in the industry yeah I was
doing a fair amount of voiceover work
until about five years ago when it sort
of started to drop off a little bit only
because I
much much busier on camera and wasn't
able to get to auditions but that has
sort of now changed because the
technology of being able to audition
from wherever you are on your smartphone
and having it sound comparatively really
good has all changed and you're able to
do that now so the voice of our stuff is
picking back up again and and another
thing I think is important is to know
how to do more than one thing beat you
don't have to be a master of all trades
but be a jack of a few voiceover stuff
on camera stuff I happen to be an expert
in a very peculiar skill called an ear
prompter it's a little wireless receiver
you wearing your ear and you record
pages and pages and pages of script onto
a microcassette recorder and you were a
little transmitter around your neck and
so you turn it on and you just follow
what you're hearing you would repeat
what you're hearing two or three or four
words behind what you're hearing and you
can you don't have to memorize anything
you can go pages and pages pages stuff
so I do that in fact that's how i did
Funny or Die presents we shot 13
episodes of this show in one day and the
only way I because they didn't have they
couldn't afford a teleprompter so the
only way you couldn't memorize that that
volume of material so I put it on my ear
prompter and we got through 13 chosen
one day and they loved me yeah so learn
how to do more than one thing I think
that's important too
you